benvenuti solida storia erano usciti dei
nuovi livelli di scary teacher che sono
anche molto romantici perché sono un
pezzo fantastiche ero già che ci
divertiremo un sacro con i scherzi lo
sceriffo è troppo divertente avete visto
l'ultimo video iscritti c'è siamo
rimasti che scrittice si è fidanzata con
il conte dracula e nei commenti avete
scritto scrittice re ha avuto più
fidanzati di me scrive racconti tanti
fidanzati di news e ho trovato che dai
nuovi livelli e voi lasciate un mi piace
e se lo lascia di un mi piace la vostra
maestro professoressa insegnante si
trasformerà in che ritirare subito mi
piace team anzi tutti i casi 7 nei
comodi poetico occorre alla federbio
scriveteci nei commenti quale lo scherzo
mi è piaciuto più di tutti anche noi vi
diremo il nostro preferito e iniziamo
subito il primo proprio se non mi
servirebbero se ritorniamo andate a
seguirmi numeri settori subito primo che
rischiò viviamo san valentino vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ha colpito sia colpito
[Musica]
che cosa signora migranti scritti certi
trasformata in cupido fa troppo ridere
tra l'altro ha tirato una freccia noi
esalto bambino noi ci siamo innamorati
della madonna
però poi viste colpite il piede e ha
visto un ragazzo fuori fatto e forse si
innamora di un ragazzo come se sarà
gelosissimo fatti lui ha detto stai
attenta a quello che colpisce perché poi
di nora ero proprio che faremo un bello
scherzetto scrittice perché se lo mette
sempre cattivi tutti i siti e la mozione
che non può ballare in giro troppo se ha
messo dei nuovi fiori sono fragole sono
fragole riprese milano più bravo e che
cani dobbiamo rischiare qualcosa nella
bevanda di scary teacher così lei perde
la mira quando tirerà dei prezzi dal
video comunque se vi piace critici come
balla se avete iniziato odio in cui se
la competizione con il vampiro e gli
altri mostri è lei che fa un balletto
beh
bellissimo io l'ho rivisto tipo dieci
volte perché mi fa troppo ridere se non
lo avete visto dopo questo video è
arrivato acquistare va detto che
scappare toccato poi cosa c'è qui una
bottigliata
bisogna mischiare qualcosa in questa
bottiglia voi schierarla e poi metterlo
nella tab sembra caffè
beh four caffè forte giusto ma che bella
la macchinetta che devo scappare
all'estero è arrivato anche perché la
coldiretti ha fatto rumore quindi
l'inter ha accordato vita o che il caffè
è pronto guardante dice di mettere il
caffè merla nella bottiglia di noi che
abbiamo premi ok abbiamo messo il cambio
nella bottiglia e lo prendiamo adesso le
fragole a cosa servono
perché dobbiamo forse dobbiamo mischiare
tutto
aiuto magari anche qualcosa si è basati
stiamo preparando un frullato vittima di
film non abbiamo varato questo livello
ma ora ritroviamo il serio se dobbiamo
far perdere loro impartite primo sistema
sappiamo da sopra adesso ok dice che
troviamo francis sta dormendo sul divano
[Musica]
l'équipe bustine odio i bambini quanto
sono antipatici lui visto che sta
arrivando le discariche è un tappo per
il per il frullatore ha forse perché ci
serviva per fondare la bevanda hockey
prendilo mille dollari mentre prende il
gioco che fa da edinson merita ok
abbiamo a prenderlo forse era quello che
ci serviva la villa fc ha scoperto dove
arriva eccole giorni modo così corriere
eccolo qui penso che si arrabbierà molto
quando scoprirà che abbiamo speso mille
giorni fa
ok abbiamo le fragole e il tappo del
frullatore e possiamo andare
indiscutibilmente vino inversamente
prima che rientri come allora aspetto
dobbiamo prendere la lattaia bottiglie
la bottiglia d'acqua che faccio a il
caffe dobbiamo prendere
del pacco non solo lui c'erano
berlusconi cosa nostra
ma il capo la investo si sia arrivato
grazie grazie
forse dobbiamo aggiungere qualcos'altro
anche allora mettiamo tutto fare al
fondatore mette il tappo anno prima gli
ingredienti bravo
forse dobbiamo aggiungere qualcos'altro
qui arrivando ghiaccio ma si fosse vero
gliela facciamo fresca se non sapete
troppo caldo ok di farti mettere il
tappo avremo carosone a korca trovi un
fallito ma non ho aspetta mi faccio
inseguire siamo che abbiamo cominciato
di se vogliamo ancora lì frullare tutto
lei è il magazine sotto non so se ok
facciamo partire sta funzionando vice di
ok dobbiamo rimettere la bottiglia
debito molto sbagliato perché non
rimanga privacy
bye michael hi fi la notte salotto buono
che altro che se lo facciamo ci aspetta
e in cucina adesso forse se sì forse se
la voce dove non si accorga che abbiamo
usato un call promotore e adesso
scappiamo parte ce l'abbiamo fatta
[Musica]
attirando la freccia ragazzo che ha
visto prima ma lo sa che non lo ha preso
e come ho preso la palla ciccata
prossimo scherzo allora dall'icona
vediamo che francis sta chiedendo rapino
che c'è stato quindi un mero già che
sarà trovano allora sei iscritto
facciamo in modo che la proposta di
francis sarà ancora più era teacher non
ha mai avuto
l'anello di fidanzamento insomma della
proposta di matrimonio quindi che cosa
parliamo
sorge allora prezzo si sta usando un
drone quindi forse vuole fare una
proposta di matrimonio poltrone
particolare con il drone magari altro ne
va e lo porta l'anello non lo so
comunque si è scritto che dobbiamo
riprogrammare il drone di francis quindi
forse iniziamo a fare qualcos'altro
siamo riprova ma prima dobbiamo trovarlo
quindi cerchiamo un po nelle stanze che
cos'è un bottone qui al piano di sopra
attenzione lei e in palestra
non mi piace qualcosa sia della colla là
sopra super più bella che ci può servire
a chi c'è qualcosa martello qualcosa
nascosto sotto il martello che pur
metterlo sotto gli altri oggetti così sa
che non lo troviamo positive come se non
hai visto ce l'ha tirato indietro a noi
si crede lo dice che dobbiamo trovare la
scatola chiusa
ora però non so perché mi sto inseguendo
ok lei sta rientrando ora possiamo
andare prendiamo atto ma perfetto ecco
le scatole regalo la chiave per aprire
questo usa la colla però da sistemare il
drone che mettiamo la colla ha forse il
pulsante valli guarda sbrigate perché
lei in giardino ordini da vicino a luca
dobbiamo capire qual è il codice che
come dice lo promo di tutti tranne il
vero dobbiamo anche sbrigarsi perché sta
arrivando
e così qua abbiamo rifatto il livello da
capo ricordiamo con il codice allora
accordo importante ora non sono tutto
non viola celeste renzone giallo e verde
qui il verde per ultimo si è ammesso la
batteria dentro adesso dice di scappare
ma vi dovrebbe essere questo il cosa
dice se lo fate anche voi io la lasciai
resta e rancio nel sonno e la fine verde
capiamo dove stiamo andando francis
[Musica]
detto dei nuovi via allora dice di
trasformare la routine di pulizie di
scary teacher in un attacco di uccelli
ha detto nessuno può fermarmi competenza
sono quegli uccelli sparissero quindi su
tubi di occhiali sparissero ma ha messo
in ghiaccio sulla porta che così sembra
ghiaccio non applicare o te sta
diventando sempre più furba un promo di
oggi c'è scritto di mettere dei semi nel
cappello di spiriti smarrimento che così
almeno la attaccheranno
ogni giorno ogni volta mi fermi in parte
dei disabili
cosa c'è in cucina guarda che cosa dire
per i temi dovrebbero essere qua
guarda un po ho avuto con sistemi ora
devo metterli nel suo cappello dove sarà
il suo cappello forse nella sua camera
da letto
c'è qualcosa qua sul tavolo su questo
mandela forse per sciogliere il ghiaccio
che ha messo sulla forca va forte
vediamo se funziona per sentire in
piazza guarda cosa ti inter mi fido si
vernice rosa o rosso al cappello quando
c'è anche un'altra vernice e buon
mischiamo tutte le dovute successo
telone un cappello e un cappello con le
scarpe speciali che vuole utilizzare per
andare a votare
ok anche bello che lo scherzo sempre
fantastica adesso però qua dove il
cappello di messi e parte camera da
letto
la palla forse cosa che non avevo lo
accogliamo non calano le rapine di sotto
quindi via cappello che brutto che cos'è
lo mettiamo la colla e poi i semini
[Musica]
bisogna stare attenti che lì non lo
scopro assicurati che non se ne accorga
quindi dobbiamo fare qualche cosa
dobbiamo fare
forse prendere il cappello mettono da
un'altra parte
no mettere una vernice sopra quella era
la stanza non me lo ricordo
ci provo a mettere la colla vediamo in
azione
no non può mettere la colla che cosa
dobbiamo mentre allora questo caso
purtroppo perché hanno fatto sì
divertiamo troppo comunque questo
scherzo dobbiamo rovinare i trucchi di
presidi presi dai trucchi per ubicare il
lieto fine di scary teacher vediamo cosa
intende dire ok ok
ok ok praticamente iscriviti sono detta
sarà una stella del party stasera e
francis li ha detto possa venire anch'io
però mi hanno descritto trasforma prezzi
si mostro di trucchi divertente è che
siamo fuori perché sta salendo salendo
di nuovo primi ma se questo è un
fazzoletto to business e di pulire la
lente di ingrandimento e toni
ho copiato la lente d'ingradimento
riprendi la lente per per vedere usa la
lente per vedere i puzzle storico
restare scoperta di noi siamo a corto ha
detto giorni sta girando qua
forse ti scrissi anche di fare lo zoom
pezzo di carta per vedere i puzzle
il primo numero ma solo degli indovini
giudizio cripto conta tutta la frutta
nella casa che verde quindi contro tutta
la frutta verde e sottrae la frutta
rossa quindi avrai la prima cifra
infatti si è scritto trova le pere e le
mele o il secondo numero brand in numero
che hai nel petto quindi dobbiamo
guardarci allo specchio per vedere però
abbiamo nel petto è capovolgi lohan
siamo il secondo numero al primo numero
poi rividi una meta che evita bastò
diventati dieci evita livello e una
professoressa di matematica schieri dice
non c'è spiegazione poi aggiungi il
numero nella faccia dell'uomo che può
farti ridere è l'uomo che ti fa ridere
questo lo dobbiamo trovare quarto numero
la cifra finale nel nome del gioco il
gioco si chiama scheri teaser 3 da3 ha
quindi l'ultimo numero e il 3 che
dobbiamo trovare tutti perché tra
l'altro tra gli indirizzi sotto in
genere scrive cosa devi fare dove devi
andare se si è scritto e scopre che
hanno voluto fare questo livello
difficile proprio ricordiamo sono ti
dobbiamo prima contare i verdi quindi le
11 12 dobbiamo sottrarre le mele
almeno otto quindi qua corrono che
abbiamo la prima cifra 4s con la seconda
cifra è ora nella nostra maglietta ha
capovolto quindi dobbiamo andare tutti
l'uomo che ride e questo c'è il numero
due questo ci servirà per la terza cifra
allora perché cifre il 2 perché diceva
no bisogna sommare le prime due cifre e
meno ok allora questo dobbiamo andare in
bagno ma perché si presenta così
dobbiamo vedere in lui a mandarci non
abbiamo nessun numero nel petto
allora c'è un problema non abbiamo
nessun numero nel feto di questo lo
controlleremo online perché altrimenti
non c'è modo di andare avanti abbiamo
dovuto vedere online non riuscivamo
andare avanti il codice 467 non abbiamo
capito bene il verdetto e voi l'avete
capito scrivete se non nei commenti così
capiamo tutti e ora di vedere il codice
in cantina ecco qua la cassaforte
ok abbiamo ascoltato il ritmo la
password nella borsa ok noi lo abbiamo
provato abbiamo già scoperto quindi in
codice 467 all aperto
cerco dentro ci sono i fumetti di
francis dice di mettere i fumetti al
posto del libro di trucchi così lui
forse si trucca come
proprio poche abbiamo sostituito due
riviste da quella di trucco a quella dei
appare noi speriamo di prestiti
trasformi mostro vediamo cosa non fa
mito avevo una ragazza scritti giorgio
rimasta malissimo
non capisco perché dice che abbiamo
fallito lo scherzo eppure sembrano
riuscito perché scritti jersey è rimasto
malissimo ho tradito con un'altra o che
stiamo rifacendo daccapo lo scherzo
perché vogliamo vedere anche l'altro
finale cioè quello riuscito guardate
allora questa volta invece di prenderle
in fumenti con il supereroe
abbiamo preso in un altro clan ventura
damon salvatore dei mostri quindi forse
è così che cambia di finale vediamo a
lei le sta dormendo
bene bene vendevo sostituire il libro
dei trucchi con questo noli e proprio lì
ma forse se dorme non se ne sport
[Musica]
questo è stato davvero davvero
divertente vediamo come reagisce scarica
[Musica]
ma le schede non sentirsi per di allora
questo secondo me è stato il più bello
perché avevi due scelti bellissimo in
entrambi grazie tuo il mio preferito è
stato quello per il drone perché vedere
che iniziavo la mia città l'area non è
fatto troppo divertente ma scrivete nei
commenti
4 primo levi il vostro proprio allora
non potete perdervi in ricerche balla
acquisibili ko per vedere gli altri
episodi schettino e se invece vuoi
vedere degli scherzi tranno ai clicca
qua invece vuoi vedere among us nella
vita reale abbiamo fatto una casa al
tesoro un bellissimo clicca col governo
a fare un altro video clicca qui il caso
pare che preferisci gara di chiarezza